[Music]
one philosopher who influenced my
thinking negara obviously a person I am
working on Bruno dick the philosopher
and con wave is there a philosopher
who's influenced you and could you talk
about their ideas or one of their ideas
the philosopher who's influenced me a
lot is David Hume the great Scot and
Hume was was a prolific philosopher who
had ideas about perception the mind the
external world but he also wrote about
philosophy and about politics a Newman
was actually somebody who in his life
had tremendous time discussing ideas
with with others he was a great friend a
number of people who lived in Paris for
a long time the French thought of him as
leborgne David a person who spoke
excellent French he was convivial he
knew that socializing was important he
knew that we shouldn't get too obsessed
by philosophy and he also knew that we
should pay attention to our bodily
experiences he was a man of the senses
he wrote a wonderful essay the standard
of taste when he tries to decide why we
can say some judgments of tastes are
better than others but also you know for
a Scot in the 18th century to say reason
is or not only to be the slave of the
passions to admit that we're more moved
by our gut feeling and by our emotions
than we are by cold rationality that was
a daring thing to say because a lot of
Scots like to think of themselves as
very reasonable but they're also boiling
up with their feelings and their
passions and you nailed that so he's a
huge influence on my thinking
so one philosopher who influenced my
thinking a lot was Frager so frege's
project was to develop a logical system
that would sort of allow us to reason in
a gap-free way but at the same time I
mean he's he's known to be one of the
most well perhaps the most important
logician there there ever was but at the
same time when he read his text
carefully he was very much clear on the
fact that logic cannot answer all open
questions and in particular logic cannot
answer the question how it is that we
gain logical knowledge how it is that we
generate the knowledge we need in order
to formulate logical axioms so I was
very interested in that idea of a sort
of an ineffable kind of knowledge that
would help us formulate logical axioms
and I then found a contemporary
philosopher working on exactly that
Adrian Moore and his philosophy has
influenced my thinking a great deal
because he actually makes a very
compelling argument for the fact that
there are ineffable kinds of knowledge
and they're everywhere and it's
perfectly coherent to argue for those so
that was that was quite an eye-opener
for me
so up until 20 or 30 years ago people
would commonly say there were no women
in the history of philosophy up until
maybe 1950 women just didn't do
philosophy they didn't exist and over
the last 20-30 years there's been a huge
recovery project to go back into the
archives and old books and say actually
no there were quite a lot of women
floating around and what's more they had
really cool philosophical things to say
so for example and the philosopher and
Conway she's active in the mid 17th
century
she has a reply to Descartes account of
what the world is like so Descartes
thought that our world is made up of
bodies and minds that these are two
different kinds of substances that that
raises a big interaction problem for one
thing if God who is supposed to be a
bigger material mind interacts with the
world how is God an immaterial being
creating things like bodies and then how
are our minds interacting with our
bodies it seems like there are two
interaction problems there then Conway
just wants to solve this by saying
everything that exists is fundamentally
immaterial and she gets rid of both
interactions in one fell swoop and she
builds up this picture of the world full
of little immaterial creatures but all
interacting with each other in different
ways
some might seem a bit more like Minds
and we're a bit more like bodies but
fundamentally they're all the same
living thing
Epictetus was one of the major historic
philosophers from the second century and
he has this beautiful way of expressing
these thoughts he said that we should
look at our impressions and impression
in stoic terminology is your initial
opinion about something so for instance
that oh my gosh I have the interview and
this is stressful this is a stressful
stress that's any that's an opinion that
that's expressing an opinion well who is
expressing the opinion the interview is
just a fact of life it's not the
interview doesn't come with opinions you
are expressing that opinion and so you
can challenge yourself and say wait a
minute
why am I thinking this way why why not
try to think about things in a different
way
and that actually does work there's
pretty good empirical evidence that you
you know it's not a silver bullet so
it's not like you start doing this
tonight and then all of a sudden your
life is fine but if you're doing a
regular basis you learn to challenge
your own impressions your own opinion
your own judgments then little by little
you it will become easier and easier and
at some point you stop having those kind
of distressing that's where the
stereotype of the lack of emotion comes
from it's not a question of suppressing
emotions it's it's a question of
controlling and interacting with your
negative thoughts I mean the the guy had
was an incredible person
he started out his life as a slave and
then he was freed started studying stoic
philosophy became the most famous
philosopher and teacher in in 2nd
century Rome he had an incredible sense
of humor and he had it was blunt movie
students just all the thing as he saw so
one for instance one of my favorite
quotes from epic Taylor says so I have
to die
well one of these days I'll have to die
apparently this is not the day but now
I'm hungry so I'm gonna go and take
lunch because that's under my control
and then when Ben comes you know we'll
deal with it at that point
well mmm you know my my unfashionable
choice will be Rene Descartes as a
classical think I think you know was of
course the founder of modern
epistemology in fact was responsible for
making epistemology they're one of the
central fields in philosophy and he is
despised these days for making too much
of the subjectivity of human experience
starting from within instead of from
without and trying very hard then to
explain how it is that we get from
inside our own heads out people really
favor these days reverse in the order of
explanation to my mind they lose the
subject matter I think subjectivity is
extremely important part of human
experience and the insights that
Descartes had both about the nature of
the mental in particular consciousness
and its distinction from the physical as
well as the epistemological tasks that
we have in explaining how we can know
anything outside our own heads still the
right way of posing most of these issues
as far as a contemporary author those
depends what you mean by contemporary
though I and I you know one person who
has influenced me a great deal witness
Stein who is the great anti Cartesian
thinker and one of the things that's
wonderful about him is because you know
he was an extremely deep and searching
thinker sometimes very hard to
understand but he and so well understood
the temptations of the Cartesian point
of view in a Cartesian setup that
although he was dead set against it with
worried him day and night
and so you get a lot of insight both
about the Cartesian view and what might
be its limitations from
thinking about work yeah well I think
the the entire classical Indian
tradition is a huge philosophical
tradition that is you know as in in
complexity at least as complex as to the
entire ancient ancient Greek and Roman
tradition so there's there's a lot of
material there and I mean I wouldn't
generally be very happy if people became
more aware of that as part of the
history of philosophy yeah but I think
they are within that they are a couple
of really interesting thinkers that
should be it should really be part of
all philosophy curricula so Nagarjuna
obviously a person I am working on but
also from from the classical Indian side
we have people like what's Yana Gianna
so the the commentator on early in Yahya
material which has a lot of a lot of
very interesting things to say
metaphysics epistemology and logic so
only said these are some of the really
big figures and I would very much hope
that they become better work better
known and and more appreciated in the in
the kind of global philosophical context
because I think philosophy in the
Western tradition is often meant to be
about argument and arguments a big role
but I think all the best philosophy is
also about they're very very careful
attending and I think there are lots of
examples of that perhaps just to give
one he's of all the films the Coen
Brothers I think they're fascinating
they're very very diverse but I think in
all those films I think you see some
very important I say philosophical
insight into into ethics and morality
actually what it means to be a good
person and what the difference is
between a good person and a bad person
and I think if you look at a lot of Coen
Brothers films you you you get kind of
three archetypes which keep recurring
there's the kind of there's the complete
sadist or they can become Percy's
completely outside or the more domain
who just has got a moral bone in their
body sort of embodiment of evil but then
you have the kind of like the
the pure in heart if you like who
actually often quite simple
straightforward people they're not
philosophers but they're just good and
decent and then you have these people
who are who are corrupted by degrees
they're not evil wicked people and yet
something things happen chain of events
they allow themselves to be corrupted
and often do really bad things and you
know without sort of going into detail
about that the film's do this since in
different ways so many of their films
are in a way showing us rather than
arguing for us important truths about
what it means to be a good person in a
world where there's so much temptation
to do wrong I've been influenced by many
things and it's so wonderful to have
this but I've got a single out mary
Midgley the wonderful english
philosopher who died recently and is
sorely missed I have to say she was a
character really interesting person but
also had some wonderful ideas and she
says look reality is so complex we need
multiple maps to try and make sense of
its different aspects you know there's
one map from science there's another
from ethics another from religion and
we're gonna try and do superimpose those
maps and get the most we can are to them
I think that's a wonderful idea I'd love
if unfortunately I can't do this if you
were here to ask her how do we draw
those maps but I know what she means and
I think it's helpful drawing maps
Gangnam right and then putting them
together and seeing the bigger picture
that emerges from those individual maps
I mean I guess AAA perhaps not very
obvious influence I was brought up in
the depths of victims Tinian well I was
actually an undergraduate and later
research fellow at San John's College
Oxford where Peter hacker and Gordon
Baker held sway at the time and so all
my early education was deeply shaped by
Vic and Stein and I still find him an
enormous ly important influence even
though sometimes I'm not quite sure why
I think I mean I'm still finding
enormous ly impressed by the famous or
infamous private language argument which
I think does show that most of the
history of philosophy that we all teach
and it taught it undergoes
undergraduates sort of you know the
Descartes to you know take our block
Berkeley Humes Banaras aliveness you
know all this tradition is based on a
fundamental mistake there's a pretty
powerful observation but it's you know I
think we we all know how to make our
students think that way we always
sometimes we don't know how to stop them
thinking that way so maybe they really
do go out of our you know lectures
thinking that there are no tables just
ideas inside their heads so this is this
is certainly a a very major influence
though probably not always that obvious
in my work for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute's of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you